jindol sincere I'm joking but he does
have some sweet sweet pig merch that
they wish I thought at first check it
out that one no hi my name is Chris hope
you don't know now you know your life is
different now it's time for favorites
I don't let's call this April and March
favorites because I don't think I did a
March favorite so let's just do it these
are things that I like slightly more
than other things at the current moment
in time that is right now okay
as always caveat with my favorites
videos some of these things have likely
been in favorites videos before but I'm
an idiot with very short term memory so
deal with it first okay I think this
might have been in my last favorites
video but I'm putting it in again this
is blush in the color rose day that I
got what I did my 7-eleven drunk makeup
tutorial yes this is 7-eleven makeup
oral and pinkish and I've been using it
every single day and I like it very much
maybe I just like it because I don't
have any other blush in my house yeah
it's better to be a favorite by default
than defunct I like it it's pretty cheap
and I think it's cute colors for the
summer I need a bucket cuz I'm just
spewing [ __ ] right now cute next
can't say anything I play this is
struggle this is NYX NYX is gotcha
Covered concealer I love this stuff
every time I go to the drugstore works
like a target I try to buy new
concealers or new eyebrow stuff for new
mascara it's just to see what is new and
also it's probably just me buying things
to fill a void who knows I picked this
up randomly from a target and I love it
I use it on my under eyes every single
day and you guys know I went to
Wrestlemania this weekend we should have
a cart on our face because we got so
many bags and this stuff has been a
goddamn delight it's a little thicker if
you don't like thick under-eye concealer
and I don't know that this is supposed
to be for under eyes or it's just
supposed to be for like blemishes but I
use it as under-eye concealer and I like
it it feels like a quilt of Photoshop
underneath my eyes and I'm here for it
next okay yeah this is
statius dip brow pomade lovely Natasha
who does my makeup when I'm in New York
City gave me a whole bunch of like free
goodies and this was one of them and
it's basically just eyebrows and it
works really well and it's in the color
that I think my eyebrows are because she
would know better than me cuz she's
makeup artist really the only
qualification for me liking any eyebrow
filler is that it matches because I can
never tell what color my eyebrows are if
they're brown it for gray if they're
blond
this is blonde oh so maybe I guess
they're blond but they're not look
that's not blonde
this is blonde what there's a lot of
layers of identity crisis happening in
this singular moment anyway this stuff
is really great and it's gonna last for
fishing ever so when the apocalypse
comes I'll be doing that till I die yeah
so yes these are glam glow face masks
and I've definitely put these in videos
before but they sent me a whole bunch of
them and these are my absolute two
favorite this one is glam glows youth
mud tingle exfoliant treatment and this
one is super mud clearing treatment
these are masks that don't around these
are like the Ronda Rousey of face masks
you put them on your face and it just
squeezes it and it feels very intense
and there's some burning and some
tingling but it feels like it's getting
all the gunk out like immersion therapy
for your face like really just forcing
it out of you and then you feel better
afterwards you guys have heard me say
having favorite videos before any time I
talk about a face mask I want to feel
that it's working you know you don't
want to get a massage and just have
someone go no you want them to get in
there yeah yeah yeah yeah if you guys
follow me on instagram at grace Helbig
across all social media platforms it's a
really fun time over there go check it
out you know that I've been obsessed
with these sunglasses I wear them every
single day and I love them so much you
can tell because they're so just covered
in grime and dirt just from my face
hence face masks got these from ASOS
calm I don't know how much they are I
think they were like 20 bucks maybe
something like that but they're
fantastic I love them look this girl
seems like she'd be annoying but below
this girl might like indie bands and
know stuff about cars and break the
stereotype of
average blonde female and I like that I
like tricking people into thinking I'm
far more interesting than I am yeah next
thing I'll say these are mohair leopard
print booties and I love them everywhere
these mohair leopard print shoes for
literally the last four years I got
these at Zara in New York City like four
years ago and I will wear them until
they completely break there's holes
everywhere I love these so much of where
these almost every single day if you put
Intel I like to look on the outside how
I feel on the inside it's okay to be
self-deprecating sometimes and every
single time I go into a Zara I look and
hope and pray that somehow they will
bring these back and I have yet to see
them anywhere if you guys know where I
can find a replacement pair of these
from Zara please please link me in the
comments down below I wish I have bought
like 17 pairs of these these are so
comfortable I get insane compliments on
them all the time these are like my Holy
Grail shoes they're so easy to put on
especially when traveling the perfect
the perfect I haven't been able to find
anything exactly like them so I got
these from ASOS also these are kind of
the closest thing I've been able to find
to those I need to wear them in they're
a little uncomfortable around this edge
beauty is pain and I wear these all at
WrestleMania and I got a ton of
compliments so I'm a Wrestlemania crowd
has any adoration for my fashion then
I'm nailing it and no one can tell me
otherwise yeah yes yeah yes yeah yes oh
yeah I got a new jumpsuit it's called
five rock I got it off of Amazon for
very cheap I love jumpsuits you know I
wear a Top Gun onesie maybe once a week
at least it's a little starchy but
aren't we all
I forget that Amazon sells clothes a lot
what are like every other thing and I
went on there because mamrie and I are
doing this new show this might get if
you haven't checked it out link down the
below are doing it five days a week and
we're providing her own wardrobe but I
have quickly run out of clothing options
to wear for our episode so I did like a
whole Amazon just like plain sweatshirt
haul and I found this guy and now
and I love it ooh a cinched waist oh wow
it really gives the body some shape does
that bucket still here coz the [ __ ]
won't stop spew it next the pockets that
I've been doing for the last four years
called not too deep which you should
listen to it comes out every Monday with
a new episode we were doing a live show
in Los Angeles once a month at this
really cool comedy venue called dynasty
typewriter the very first show will
behavioral 26 at 8:00 p.m. at dynasty
typewriter it's gonna be myself Jack
Barry and we'll be having a guest and or
guests but we will be announcing that
very soon but in the meantime you didn't
buy your ticket so if you live in or
around the Los Angeles area the link is
in the description box below please go
go go we'll be doing this once a month
but the very first show is always the
most exciting and nerve-racking and the
most fun to be at because it's got the
most bloops because we don't know what
the [ __ ] we're doing exactly yet so
these your tickets now I'd love to see
your shining grimy faces there okay
that's it for my favorites for this
month you guys like this video I want me
to continue doing ferrets video give it
a thumbs up and do not forget to
subscribe to this YouTube chat with that
bow notification hugs as you've seen my
schedules all over the place I'm trying
to get it in order but I'm always trying
to please hit that Bell notification
because I know subscription boxes and
all of that is constantly up and who am
I to judge because but set yourselves up
for success so that if the notifications
are working you get them because I'd
love for you to watch these videos other
than that I don't know what do you get
when Blake Lively it's a mechanic this